o nariz de palhaço aqui já que é
obrigada pela homenagem do ted a todos
nós palhaços muito bem pensado
é essa aí com tanta dúvida neco a
abordagem dele quer alargar o ipad
pergunta tanta coisa que como cidadão
dizer não sei nada tite é preciso
perguntar a batata agora eu vou sair
daqui com batons da linha já vem da omm
diz na cara eu também né
an por que a gente consome ea gente
produz ea gente trabalha ea gente nesse
sentido eu espero que qualquer fronteira
que no palco nós chamamos isso de
fronteira no teatro nós chamamos essa
linha de que naquele espaço de suspensão
facul pra que haja o encontro poético
entre público e o atuante o atuador mas
eu espero que isso realmente não seja
visto como fronteira
eu até percebo e do palco para olhar pra
gente está junto
nesses 18 minutos se a gente consegue
enquanto sociedade brasileira e anti
humano horizontalizar alguma coisa eu
vou sair daqui vou perguntar da
abobrinha vou perguntar da carne
eu vou perguntar de quem já foi
presidente de quem tá sendo agora vou
cobrar tudo isso eu vou perguntar pra
ele como ele faz uma política de afeto
não sabe a então nesse sentido eu
realmente não sei eu quero trazer para
vocês é o que eu não sei e não o que eu
sei porque sou palhaça justamante foi
parar nessa profissão porque eu não
nadei bem em outras
eu vim até com uma blusinha de coruja
problema já não é que ela sim é uma
literatura formada pela usp e ela saúda
muito o anel dela de coruja de tecla
coisa da colação de grau que hoje meu
sobrinho está fazendo colação de grau
minha mãe tá lá com ele uma família tem
seus burocratas acadêmicos no não é um
grande executivo das vendas ea caçula ea
família vai investir no uma palhaça né
com ela vai se investir isso porque na
verdade eu queria ser atriz trágica
sempre compensa o que é verdade
tá eu queria ser atriz de teatro já
conta um pouco do que se motivou eu
queria ser a 3 de tragédia quando falo
para vocês pra gente igualá-lo de
fronteiras é porque na verdade eu não
acho uma palhaçada sem fronteiras do
méxico uma palhaça um artista hoje um
segundo
tá dessas 18 minutos hoje com muitas
fronteiras mapas que não toma como
trazer para vocês aqui porque nós
estamos muito divididos
fazemos parte de uma sociedade dividida
nós amamos vocês sabem do que estou
falando nesse momento na manta acolhendo
o seu neto no outro lugar numa faculdade
formação de marketing
ela tem uma fama de alguma maneira vai
romper com isso mas como conviver junto
com isso essa é a pergunta eu queria
perguntar pra vocês
somos três pessoas de universos
completamente distintos quando que a
gente vai fazer então eu vim aqui pra
dizer para vocês que eu não sei mas
antígona que eu estudei mas vamos tratar
de aristófanes medalha choque
com seus reis esses caras não formaram
muito e pintaram trazer alguma
provocação da cne em se eu pudesse agora
outra ser um pouco para estar no mesmo
nível de olhar que vocês
ou você subiria um dos meus mestres que
se chama jato e coque eu já vou chegar
lá eu sou geminiana conseguinte peixes e
sua palhaça
eu sou do teatro da comédia física faz
única portanto pra falar isso mas graças
à minha mãe pra isso é o meu mestre de
de uma das escolas que não falou ele
traz uma poética com as bandas e santi
para a gente agora nesse enquanto que é
de fato a linha do horizonte do ator
está no aguardo do outro
entendo que estou falando
poeticamente o meu encontro com os com
você se dá com a verdade do nosso olhar
os meus amores
ninguém vai tirar então com o vejo na
minha família uma labuta grande dos meus
pais informar seus filhos
eu via na obrigação de ser essa figura
que tem que surpreender porque eu nasci
em 1975 e nos anos 80 era o que você tem
que vencer
você tem que ver palestra do águas
bravas você tem que ser longo
você tem que saber falar achei a sua
coluna você tem que ver você tem que ser
incrível realmente não consegui atingir
na lista pálpebra onde naquela restou de
uma super executiva eu não atingir a
meta é o teatro que me acolheu
a rua que me acolheu e foi na
adolescência que me acolheu e foi a
morte do meu pai que me acolheu e foi o
tempo que me falando a vivo disse nada
que queremos falar sobre que me colocou
mais de 12 países que me colocou
francofônica e pague o fônica que fala
a empresa fabrica e tantas outras
fônicos como o meu próprio corpo e foi
liberada e aborto própria família passou
de um sonho
falando nisso tudo que ouvi um fragmento
de meu papel aqui e nunca conseguiu
fazer de um antigo né que eu nunca
consegui fazer toda vez que a prova
tragédia improvisada as pessoas riam de
mim não desgraçadamente era muito com o
mesmo tudo isso que me colocou no bar do
riso e foi tudo isso que me fez até a
fundação casa por um voto não e por um
voto deles porque a gente teve um
encontro mágico ou esses jovens trazendo
muito boa graficamente porque é um ponto
é crucial da minha história se dá conta
de alguma forma evento algumas
fronteiras dentro de casa a partir de
uma sexualidade
quando eu perco meu pai para ver
e aí pra minha família é delicado e
delicada placar e surge em dia mas eu
tenho contrato com eles nada que desfaça
imagem em nada que diz respeito a
qualquer título à minha família por tudo
que a gente já viveu e tanto que minha
mãe passou porque ela foi muito
desrespeitada na rua dela pelas pessoas
que a conheciam e por tudo que ela
passou e ela está saudável essa ferida
este lugar
esse peso o casamento me abri
a segunda diz um dia em lábrea até para
conseguir disse coisas mãos porque a
gente tem um lugarzinho pretende de
sociedade ea gente tem mesmo um pacto
lante de achar que aborto assunto e um
outro de que o cara é pobre por opção de
que fulano criminoso por opção de que o
cara pegou do evento ninguém lhe trair a
mulher dele
então a gente vai crescendo com isso e
toda aquela capa da família doriana faz
assim ó e pelo profundo ser uma
margarina nasci aqui existe mais
orgânica hoje em dia mesmo eu quero que
pergunte onde van
eu quero ser essa batata nós precisamos
logo que levante legal vou fazer vou
criar um novo governo
permiti-me de batata eu sou deputado
falando isso pra vocês porque eu tô
traduzindo essa maneira tão caótica
porque não têm como uma sociedade como a
nossa e um planeta como o nosso a gente
querer quebrar por uma única forma
nesse sentido o palhaço traduza a vida
pelo contratempo pelo erro é ele que
acha praxe na tragédia para
ridicularizar o mundo
os bufos e vocês podem pesquisar sobre
isso que a minha pesquisa manhã e é por
conta de ser neta detalhou no músico por
conta desse neta de um cara que fugiu de
casa porque a palavra dos pais aos oito
anos de idade preparará com 15 em uma
fazenda e um pelo outro vôo é toda essa
história toda essa soma se esses contos
que fazem a gente traduzir em forma de
como a cidade e conseguir tudo isso os
bufos fazem parte disso pensar
quer dizer expandir em chahr bufos são
aquelas figuras míticas que estão na
comédia vem para ridicularizar satirizar
e para o diário
num olho que eu tô falando pra vocês
então quando ellen degeneres para uma
série de televisão e fala para que eu
tenho uma coisa pra revelar
eu sou lésbica quando o ator negro um
óscar pela primeira vez os atores negros
que a gente já tô lá na frente como cara
fala quando fala quando a meryl streep
enfrenta não precisa falar nomes
enfrenta quem ela enfrentou é muito
debilitado pra gente como artista
conciliar isso com a sociedade quando
ela não está na profissão do artista
mas o curioso é que a gente tem em todo
lugar não vai dar pra fechar nossos
teatros nos cinemas entendido que eu tô
falando o circo é uma agora eu não sou
palhaço de circo e para eles eu peço
licença para ser mas o que eu passo para
as meninas lá é que a água do circo é
porque todos nós trabalhamos em uma
coluna em comum na telinha comum como no
olho horizonte
então nesse sentido a rapaziada como
eles disse
dizem que a pergunta maior de vocês
porque uma palhaça dentro da fundação
casa na estrutura que vocês devem saber
muito bem que não é simples e que a
sociedade antes de cobrar de qualquer
liderança a gente vai ter que se revê
nós temos na história o conjunto de
lideranças erradas e por favor pode
pedir licença à escravidão foi algo
grave no país
então se vocês querem saber de mim como
se dá a nossa dinâmica dentro da
fundação casa
vocês precisam mais que biologicamente
olhar historicamente pressa para um lar
em chamada brasil e que antes não era
brasil
precisa povo branco e pedir licença
então quando eu fui pra frente eu
aprendi isso quando eu fui pra amazônia
eu aprendi isso e agora apenas com os
meus alunos e quer dar um salvo para
eles os que estão lá dentro eles me
pediram unidade de taipas feminina
mário covas masculina em unidade bela
vista
salvo para todos vocês me pediram sair a
salvos para os que estão em liberdade
ontem saiu num salvo pra você não posso
falar se o nome que tem proteção do
estado
salve pra você sabe a zona leste salvar
o nosso saudoso norte salvo zona oeste
são esses meninos que estão lá dentro
são esses meninos que a sociedade não
está conseguindo enxergar se você de
fato querem trocar sobre isso se a gente
quiser falar sobre isso
eu sou parte da sociedade junto com
vocês eu não sei se já cometido um crime
talvez no amor porque sou péssima mãe
nunca deu certo na cadeira está vazia
não vai ter jogo vai rolar mas rica com
eles eles são os humanos não ter como
explicar a rotina só posso dizer pra
vocês que dão entrou na unidade da
fundação casa eu dou aula de teatro e
passou por percalços como eu passo na sp
escola de teatro me a outra entidade que
o trabalho
são entidades públicas do governo do
estado também um trabalho para entidades
municipais infernais
nesse sentido o artista ainda precisa de
cor público é provado e que eles se
entendam e logo para que nós possamos
atua nesse sentido que eu faço dentro da
fundação casa é tudo aquilo que eu tenho
condições de fazer com os meus
aprendizes atores que eu dirijo em
outros lugares
porém comuns advindos jovens de uma
outra realidade maior é apontar o dedo e
num olhar para aquele
o um ramo maior é a grande piada que o
planeta tem vivido num maior é o que a
gente se faz com a perda de afeto prêmio
maior é fazer piada da miséria humana
maior é parar de achar que já tem um por
dois ou três heróis que vão fazer alguma
coisa por nós crime maior é a gente não
estabeleceu a horizontalidade e varrer
essa fronteira
nós somos administradores engenheiros
médicos artistas advogados nós somos
quem sou eu pra falar pra vocês da minha
potência do riso nos amores os seus
elétrons ensino
o artista precisa estar vivo o poeta
precisa tá vivo o advogado precisa tá
vivo esse cara precisa estar com a gente
e cítara precisa estar com a gente todo
mundo vai ter que estar junto para
entender que dentro da pelo muro e fora
daquele muro e se já vão precisa de uma
formação e de afeto como nós tivemos por
isso que a gente não tentar ser itu vez
é porque não costura não põe papá
parafusa harold invés de fazer nenhum se
espalha no bota ele acentua a corrente
nele bater uma lavoura mas manda
trabalhar com essa forma a gente é bom
como sociedade obviamente que não é essa
a prática nos amores é outra é outra
eles nascem eles não são consumidos
eu sei que você sabe do que estou
falando não estou aqui para julgar
ninguém
que por representar uma entidade
terceirizada ou não o que a gente
precisa assim entender
só isso que eu acho que a gente abra uma
brecha de 18 minutos abre todo dia na
brecha de 18 minutos da sua vida e às
vezes talvez não estamos no amor
companheiro porque a gente prefere ficar
no grupo d a zap mostrando as amigas
descoladas da vida e os amigos
talvez a gente tenha cadeira vazia do
que a gente está numa realidade paralela
e esquece de quem está lá no outro lugar
querendo fazer viver não faça o bolo
eles não são vítimas eles não pedem para
utilizar eu vou encerrar o que acontece
é que eles são parte são da sociedade
a minha rotina com eles é deliciosa eu
não sofro rebelião
nós temos problemas sim problemas
estruturais mas enquanto educadores e
artistas eles nos respeitam
dentro da fundação casa não estou
sozinha nós temos uma equipe maravilhosa
e de um salve para todos eles
rappers capoeiristas maravilhosos bom
como sp escola de teatro onde eu
trabalho e uma equipe de profissionais
isso para dizer que a artista trabalha
que nós precisamos artista
todo mundo já foi gostaria de provar
veneza não gostaria
é uma terra de artistas de pura arte
todo mundo adora fazer um post em paris
tem grandes artistas lá bahia que não
quer fazer lista o campeão em salvador
eles são artistas e eles não são
entretenimento
nós estamos juntos e queremos estar
juntos esses meninos têm duarte
vocês podem ter certeza o salve deles
você outro lado um salve para vocês que
assim que eles fazem
a chave aqui pra caramba pode parar é
nós
bom eu sou confusa da um gol aí eu não
tô nem magoado nas duas naves
mas toda a vida toda história tem cartaz
e é isso que eu queria agradecer à
sensibilidade e encontra obrigada pelos
organizadores para se assim foi muito
ruim
não tá bom
[Aplausos]